ah
[Música]
se acuerda de la primera vez que
escucharon hablar de vih yo sí fue más o
menos en el año 1993 cuando salió la
película filadelfia yo sabía que trataba
sobre una extraña enfermedad en ese
entonces era yo muy pequeño y no me
dejaron verla así que fue hasta años
después cuando era adolescente que
volvía a hablar sobre vih cuando tenía
dudas sobre sexualidad en la escuela en
realidad no nos enseñaron mucho
en ese entonces pues en internet no
había mucho contenido
los libros tenían un contenido bastante
obsoleto así que afortunadamente
encontré una organización de la sociedad
civil que estaba cerca de mi casa mexfam
la fundación mexicana para la
planificación familiar donde me
resolvieron mis dudas también me dieron
consejería y me invitaron a ser
voluntario a partir de ahí empecé a dar
charlas con mis padres adolescentes y me
di cuenta de la gran importancia que
tenía hablar no sólo de vih sino de
otros temas de salud sexual y
reproductiva bueno entre la universidad
seguí siendo voluntario y en mis tiempos
libres pues también le hablaba a otros
universitarios acerca del vih me di
cuenta que existían muchísimos mitos y
estos mitos por ejemplo eran aquellos
que salían en la televisión por ejemplo
había campañas que nos decían qué
si tenías más de una pareja sexual
irremediablemente te ibas a acabar
muriendo de sida había folletos que te
decían que la única forma de prevenir el
vih era la fidelidad o también había ya
saben los típicos médicos que te
enseñaban unas galerías del terror sobre
lo monstruosas que podrían ser las
infecciones de transmisión sexual estos
mitos obviamente llegaban a todo el
mundo y son aquellos que hasta la fecha
tenemos más o menos en la cabeza por
ejemplo mis compañeros del salón
pensaban algunos que a través de un
piquete de mosquito podías adquirir vih
o que si éste metías a una alberca donde
había una persona que tuviera el virus
también podían transmitir te lo
afortunadamente pues años después surgen
las redes sociales en internet a través
de las cuales podemos compartir mucho
más información específica sobre vih por
ejemplo
cuando yo empecé en el activismo pues
cuando querías difundir una campaña por
ponías un póster en algún lugar público
hoy en día pues más bien compartimos
imágenes compartimos memes compartimos
vídeos a través de facebook de twitter
de youtube de instagram y todas estas
otras redes en las cuales además nos
permite encontrar por ejemplo la
población específica a la que queremos
dar mensajes mucho más claros e incluso
mucho más atrevidos yo abrí más mis
redes sociales más o menos hace unos
diez años por ahí del 2009 abrió una
cuenta de twitter empecé a colaborar en
algunos vídeos de youtube otras personas
empecé a escribir también algunos
artículos en páginas específicas
dirigidas a la población al gmt y de
esta forma me di cuenta de la
importancia de que podía llegar a mucho
más gente con mis mensajes y algo que
también me di cuenta es que las redes
sociales así como pueden ser muy
positivas muchas veces también pueden
ser muy negativas y esto tiene que ver
con las famosas fake news las noticias
falsas relacionadas con muchos temas
incluyendo aquellos relacionados con la
salud sexual y por supuesto aquellos
relacionados con el vih quien no ha
recibido por ejemplo una cadena de
whatsapp donde dice que el condón no
sirve para prevenir el vih porque el
virus es más chiquito que los poros de
látex o quien no ha visto por ejemplo
vídeos donde nos dicen que el sida no
existe y que en realidad son inventos de
las farmacéuticas a ver levanten la mano
a aquellas personas que están presentes
en esta sala que alguna vez hayan
escuchado este mito este mensaje de que
en los
es en los antros hay gente con jeringas
llenas de sangre esté con vih que andan
picando a la gente por ahí para
transmitírsela no bueno pues veo que la
mayoría entonces ahí nos podemos dar
cuenta que a veces muchas redes sociales
pueden ser un arma de doble filo y en
ese sentido es muy importante que
tengamos información científica estos
mitos también no son exclusivos de la
población en general también suceden por
ejemplo entre el personal de salud a mí
me ha tocado muchas veces escuchar
personal de enfermería médicos que dicen
las mujeres embarazadas las mujeres que
viven con vih no deberían embarazarse
porque ponen en riesgo la salud y la
vida de sus hijos a pesar de que hace
más de 10 años que tenemos muchísima
evidencia de que una mujer que vive con
vih que utiliza tratamiento y que tiene
una carga viral indetectable se puede
embarazar sin tener el menor riesgo de
transmitir el vih a su hijo ni en
durante el embarazo ni durante el parto
ni en la lactancia y esta discusión
también la he visto trasladada a twitter
donde por ejemplo me he peleado con
algunos médicos que por más que les
mandes cinco artículos científicos que
demuestran estás
te dicen no en mi experiencia no es así
y no voy a creer en esta circunstancia
yo por eso por ejemplo cuando pongo
algún tweet cuando escribo algún
artículo trato siempre de poner fuentes
de pues obviamente de los estudios
científicos de los reportes de algunas
conferencias internacionales de
investigación o incluso con los
encabezados por ejemplo de algunas de
algunos medios de comunicación que
hablan sobre el tema obviamente esto no
significa que sean verdades universales
por ejemplo ellos en los últimos tres
años he visto al menos unos sin unas
cinco veces encabezados como este donde
se nos dice que científicos en tal país
descubrieron la cura del vih lo cual
obviamente no es cierto pero es
parcialmente
solamente es parcialmente cierto porque
es probable que en alguna parte del
mundo en algún laboratorio encontraron
resultados positivos a nivel celular con
ratones con monos pero eso
definitivamente no significa que ya está
lista una jeringa para aplicarse a las
38 millones de personas que hoy en día
viven con vih para eso probablemente
todavía vamos a tener que esperar unos
o incluso unos 10 años vivimos en una
época de post verdad donde también nos
cuesta mucho trabajo aceptar las
noticias buenas que hay allá afuera y
una de ellas es indetectable e iguala
intransmisible y aquí voy a hacer un
paréntesis para hablar de los
antirretrovirales para caer en este tema
de la indetectabilidad los medicamentos
antirretrovirales son medicamentos que
desde los años 90 sirven para que las
personas que viven con vih puedan
controlar la replicación del virus y
digamos que si bien el virus no se
elimina del cuerpo está digamos que por
ahí escondido y no se tiene una persona
que por ejemplo tiene una buena
adherencia es decir que utiliza el
medicamento de forma constante
como lo dice el médico es decir tomarse
sus pastillas todos los días puede
llegar a un estado de indes decir la
cantidad de virus es tan chiquita que no
se puede transmitir incluso si se
llegaran a tener relaciones sexuales sin
condón ahora después de muchos años se
hicieron estudios en muchos países con
muchas poblaciones en diferente con
diferentes metodologías y todas nos
dieron el resultado de qué
indetectable es igual a intransmisible a
pesar de todos estos estudios yo todavía
me encuentro mucha gente que me dice ah
pero es que mi primo que es médico me
dijo que eso no es cierto no sabes que
vi un vídeo de youtube donde dice lo
contrario no es que me dijo mi prima que
tal cosa entonces todas estas cuestiones
las tenemos que combatir porque no
necesariamente nos dan la información
más adecuada los medios de comunicación
y las personas que nos dedicamos un poco
a informar sobre estas situaciones
también tenemos mucho que ver con el
estigma y la discriminación relacionada
con el vih
seguramente han leído algún titular de
algún periódico que dice un sido so
contagio a tantas personas o su esposo
le transmitió una enfermedad mortal todo
este lenguaje muchas veces es súper
negativo porque provoca que los estigmas
y la discriminación que existen en el
país se perpetúen hoy por hoy de acuerdo
por ejemplo a la encuesta nacional de
discriminación de la conapred vemos que
el vih está dentro de las tres
principales causas de discriminación en
este país discriminación particularmente
a nivel de la familia y a nivel del
trabajo afortunadamente también vemos
que los mensajes han empezado a cambiar
hay muchos comunicadores muchos medios
que están utilizando un lenguaje mucho
más adecuado y por ejemplo en mi caso me
sucede que algunos amigos que son
reporteros se acercan y me dicen oye te
puedo mandar una nota que escribí para
que cheques si no estoy dicen alguna
barbaridad o si no estoy utilizando el
lenguaje que sea estigmatizante todo
esta información definitivamente es
clave para eliminar el estigma y la
discriminación volviendo un poquito al
tema de la evidencia científica también
hay que reconocer que muchas veces
por una persona que no ha estudiado por
ejemplo una carrera relacionada con las
ciencias médicas a veces no va a poder
entender un artículo sobre infectología
sobre biología sobre hiperión
epidemiología y en mi caso una una de
las razones por las cuales decidí
estudiar un posgrado en salud pública
fue además por de por supuesto seguir
apoyando en la respuesta a la epidemia
del vih poder hacer también una especie
de traductor y de divulgador del
conocimiento para que más gente pudiera
acceder a las cosas más novedosas no
solamente en materia de vih sino incluso
en otro tipo de materias y aquí es donde
quiero hablarles en particular de un par
de métodos de prevención que son
relativamente nuevos y que probablemente
muchos y muchos de ustedes ya hayan
escuchado pero a la cual hay muchas
dudas porque de repente recibimos
mensajes contradictorios de repente por
un lado del gobierno por otro lado de
las organizaciones de la sociedad civil
por otro lado de las empresas
farmacéuticas pero pues qué pasa con la
pep y la prueba
estas son la profilaxis postexposición y
la profilaxis preexposición y les voy a
platicar un poquito de qué se tratan
ambos son tratamientos que ayudan a la
prevención y que se basan también en
medicamentos antirretrovirales en el
caso de la pep es una especie de
pastilla anticonceptiva de emergencia
que se tiene que empezar a utilizar
dentro de las 72 horas posteriores a
haber tenido una relación sexual de
riesgo esto permite que en el caso de
que por ejemplo yo haya tenido ya yo
haya sido víctima de violencia sexual o
en el caso del personal de salud que
hayamos tenido algún contacto con alguna
jeringa en el hospital podamos utilizar
este tratamiento durante un mes y de
esta forma reducir significativamente el
riesgo de adquirir vih por otro lado
está la prep que es un método que
incluso se habla mucho más y que en
algunos países ya está provocando
cambios enormes en la epidemia como es
el caso por ejemplo de eeuu es el caso
de algunos países europeos la prep es un
medicamento que se puede utilizar por
parte de las personas que están en mayor
riesgo adquirir vih o que pertenecen a
las poblaciones clave y que se puede
utilizar de manera manera
definida sea por algunos meses o por
algunos años y de esta forma digamos que
se crea una especie de barrera
protectora en el cuerpo que no permite
que el virus entre a nuestro organismo
ahora esto no es tan sencillo no no son
aspirinas hay que hacerse una serie de
pruebas antes de poderlo utilizar es un
medicamento pues que es más o menos caro
y que en el caso de méxico no está
ampliamente disponible de hecho
solamente existe a través de algunos
protocolos de investigación en algunas
ciudades como está la ciudad de méxico y
en guadalajara
ahora la pep y la prep no funcionan por
sí solas no te tiene que haber un
paquete de digamos que integral de
prevención que nos permita modificar
nuestros comportamientos pero también
tiene que existir medidas estructurales
que permitan disminuir nuestra
vulnerabilidad al vih poder tomar por
ejemplo decisiones sobre nuestro cuerpo
y también no hay que olvidar que el gran
campeón de la prevención durante los 35
años de epidemia que llevamos en méxico
han sido los condones sin embargo
también tenemos que reconocer que los
condones no han sido del todo efectivos
para todo el mundo para muchísima gente
por supuesto que han ayudado a evitar
miles o incluso millones de
casos sin embargo también hemos visto
por ejemplo que en los últimos 10 años
ni hemos subido ni hemos bajado en
nuevas infecciones tenemos un promedio
de entre 12 y 15 mil nuevos casos de vih
al año esto nos dice que no podemos
seguir haciendo las mismas cosas de
siempre es decir no podemos confiar
solamente en los condones sino que
tenemos que confiar en el tratamiento
como prevención es decir la
indetectabilidad y tenemos que confiar
también en las nuevas tecnologías como
la pep y la prepa pero también en otro
tipo de intervenciones como es por
ejemplo la educación integral en
sexualidad para los adolescentes y niños
o disminuir la violencia de género y la
violencia homo transfóbica que nos hace
que tengamos mucho mayor vulnerabilidad
al vih dentro de algunos años es
probable que tengamos una vacuna que
prevenga el vih o incluso una cura que
ayude a que las personas que ya viven
con el virus puedan eliminarlo de su
cuerpo pero en lo que esto pasa tenemos
que seguir confiando en la información
basada en evidencias científicas tenemos
que volvernos todos y todas aliadas de
la lucha y de la respuesta y esto como
lo podemos hacer por ejemplo
compartiendo nuestras redes sociales
vídeo
dos campañas haciendo algunas acciones
como las que están haciendo diversos
medios como soy homosexual como
escándalo como pepe y theo que han
abierto sus puertas para hablar de estos
temas porque son muy importantes para
nuestra comunidad una de las cosas que
para mí ha sido por ejemplo muy
reconfortante de participar en estos
espacios de las redes sociales y de los
vídeos es que a veces por ejemplo al
final de un evento o en algún espacio
público se me acerca a alguien que no
conozco y me dice oye gracias a un tweet
que pusiste me enteré que existía la
profilaxis postexposición en un momento
de emergencia en que la necesitaba o
alguien más que me ha dicho por ejemplo
oye gracias a un artículo que leí que
escribiste me animé a hacerme la prueba
de vih u otra persona que de repente me
dice oye te bien está el vídeo y gracias
a eso supe que existe una vacuna para el
vph y de hecho hace apenas unos días me
pasó en una fiesta que se acercó un
chico y me dice oye tú no me conoces
pero hace algunos años yo descubrí que
vivían con vih y me quería morir pero te
escribí por twitter y tú me respondiste
sin saber quién era
y me dijiste que me tranquilizara me
dijiste cómo acceder al tratamiento y
gracias a esto sigo vivo me siento sano
y estoy muy bien mírame este tipo de
cosas para mí son súper importantes
porque son las que me dicen que todo el
esfuerzo que estamos haciendo vale la
pena no solamente yo sino muchas
organizaciones de la sociedad civil que
están presentes aquí acompañándonos esta
noche para ir cerrando me gustaría
invitarles obviamente a que nos sigamos
protegiendo a que nos hagamos la prueba
del vih al menos una vez al año si
tenemos una vida sexual activa a que si
ya vivimos qué envidia che nos adhiramos
al tratamiento y sólo de esta forma
vamos lograr vamos a lograr detener la
epidemia existen países tan diversos
como dinamarca botsuana o camboya donde
prácticamente la epidemia se está
empezando a detener y esto tiene que ver
con la voluntad política los recursos
económicos que se están implementando
las estrategias adecuadas pero además
que se están involucrando a las
comunidades más afectadas por el vih que
en el caso de méxico y la mayoría de los
países de américa latina somos las
mujeres trans las personas que se
dedican al trabajo sexual y los hombres
gays y los hombres bisexuales todas
nuestras comunidades
a la población en general tenemos que
unirnos y yo creo que en méxico lo
podemos lograr yo sí creo que en méxico
podemos hacer que para el año 2030 no
haya nuevos casos de vih no hayan
muertes relacionadas con el sida y
también acabemos con el estigma y la
discriminación muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
a
[Música]